[Music]
bachelor in paradise has halted
production on its sports season due to
allegations of misconduct after an
incident between Corrine elympios and
fellow cast mate Demario Jackson but as
a result of the controversy it seems we
may have learned a few paradise cast
spoilers remember Demario was the only
contestant from rachael lindsay season
of The Bachelorette that was confirmed
to appear on the show but here's diggie
and Iggy who are still in the running to
win Rachel's heart they were spotted
traveling with VIP cast member derik
leading to speculation they may not have
received Rachel's final rose they also
did a live Q&A on Instagram Monday so a
few things that we're not taking
questions about we are not seems like
something happened in Paradise not going
to test that at all the Internet is your
friends just let you know also still
vying for a chance at love with Rachel
Jack stone who posed for a group photo
with the cast at the port of iata
airport and these silly snaps hanging
with the VIP squad
[Music]
you